if I if I have somebody my company wants
to take risk I say oh no I'll go work
somewhere else there's only one thing
you can do eight hours a day and that's
work I mean my friends were some of the
richest people in the world and they
were a little bit they weren't really
together people asked me when when do
you want this and my usual answer is
three four follow your dreams but make
sure it's the right dream you know if
you're if your dream is to be a serial
killer please please don't do that if
you're gonna go out there and sell it
you use it yourself is your family use
it and if they don't buy you something
if you aggravate you gotta go it's not
them there should be something to do
that's useful that's something that says
okay I did something it's like anything
else if you ask a customer what they
need they'll give you the wrong answer
my first question usually is to an MBA
how are you gonna get over it he's an
Indian American businessman and
philanthropist he's the founder and CEO
of innovations Ventures LLC he has an
estimated net worth of 1.5 billion
dollars he's Manoj Bhargava and here his
top 10 rules for success somebody asked
me I think that we're just having an
interview and somebody asked me well
should we have risk takers you know
entrepreneurs risk takers and I said no
no no no no entrepreneurs are not risk
takers you know if if I if I have
somebody in my company who wants to take
risks I say or not I'll go work
somewhere else you know our job as
entrepreneurs is to minimize risk to
manage risk to give it to somebody else
not take it if you want to take risk go
to Vegas
you know it's a really simple concept
but if you tell people you should be
risk-takers they go out there and just
blow your money any that's it's really
dumb
yeah and again like I said you know our
other print principle is please don't do
dumb I think there's a there's a
misconception that if you're a
billionaire that must be you must go out
and your Butler brings you tea and the
tea garden or something I get up and I
get ready for a bowl of cereal
yeah what's your favorite cereal I'm not
gonna start with that but you know I put
the milk in I eat the cereal drive to
work and then I work like hell I work
hard if I can't you know if there's work
to get done I'm doing it and at the end
of the day I mean it's really not that
different I mean there's somebody who
said there's only one thing you can do 8
hours a day and that's work and what if
what if you enjoy your work I mean to me
it's football basketball cricket all in
one work is great fun and I'm I kind of
we've made our business so that it is
fun you know everybody there enjoys it
and we have certain conditions in the
company that if you don't enjoy it go
work somewhere else so why do you drop
out of Princeton well I was first of all
I don't hate Princeton that was a miss
never representation how much the
presenter shaded by somebody who went to
University of Pennsylvania okay so
beyond the college rivalry or the school
rivalry
why do you drop out well I as I mean the
Princetonian just interviewed me a few
days ago and I wanted to clear the air
because I never said they were bad yeah
and the purpose really to me was look I
got it was great for a year and they
said why a year I said look it's the
same reason why nobody stays for five
years why fight why four years I mean
it's an arbitrary number yeah I got what
I needed out of Princeton in one year
and after that I didn't think it was
useful partially because look you go to
school and the primary reason is you
want to make some money you want to get
a good job and you make some money it
wasn't important to me
I mean I thought I mean my friends were
some of the richest people in the world
and they were a little bit they weren't
really together they were sort of messed
up a lot of them and I thought what is
this I'm trying to be like that that
makes no sense so then I thought okay I
don't need this and let me find
something that's more useful planning is
I mean it has to be related to something
in other words if its product is it so
you have to look at it that way we look
at it simple if a product idea comes in
I can't plan for a product idea to come
in that's slam dunk if a product idea
comes in we're ready to go execute right
now and the way we do it is on the
planning side of execution you know a
bunch of stuff they say well this is
going to take six months and I don't
allow that because what people do is
wait five months there's five and a half
months and then start I want to know
people ask me when when do you want this
and my usual answer is three o'clock and
every day my view is the next day what
can you do today do your maximum right
now today and so unfortunately some
planning can actually go backwards
because they say well you know everybody
else takes a year how is that relevant
you know to me it's like no no three
days four days let's go so there's a lot
of areas which planning is is is
actually counterproductive the problem
with everyone is they follow fashion
right you do what's everybody all your
peers think it's cool Pantheon things
you know this is right now it's cool to
start a business in Silicon Valley and
get rich that's the when I was one hours
in in the early late 60s early 70s it
was the entirely the opposite it was get
out drop out do something else
so people tend to both or have both are
really irrelevant you know in the sense
that fashion isn't what and it should
define your life right what everybody
does what everybody says shouldn't
define life the ideal thing is to do
something that has value right people
say follow your dreams I think at one
game one time I gave a speech I said
follow your dreams but make sure it's
the right dream you know if you're if
your dream is to be a serial killer
please please don't do that
right so it's it's sort of think with
your head although I know movies say
don't think with your heart no think
with your head do that which is you know
has strength which has meaning and if
you do that which has meaning your life
is better most businesses are the same
whether you're selling
energy products or any consumer products
if it's useful to people the rest is
just business
so if you find something or invent
something that's really useful
at that point it's really common
whatever you're selling
process is not that different
and our process is maybe a little bit
different because we really don't have
em b a.type processing we basically
common sense we look at businesses
really in a simple way make good stuff
and you solid instead of you know all
the pie falutin words which I really
don't understand like brand awareness
and brand equity and
all the fancy terminologies people use
that they don't have proper so we what
we did was they simply simply stick to
fundamentals which is they make a really
good product and eighty percent of
marketing is making a really good car
and you go out there and if people like
it
they agree with you then they buy
actually you'll find most of the
products that they say are good our mark
most of the folks that come up with
products usually use some kind of a
given in other words gee let's make it
pink if it's for women let's me
what's his name famous person endorsing
products themselves marginal and then
they say what's a good product
Wow my question is do you use it if
you're going to go out there and sell it
you use it yourself
does your family use it and if they
don't why are you selling
so really you'll find most of the
fellows that say we have great products
we didn't get success if they really
don't use the product they think
everybody else should not us we're
superior our own product so there's a
there's a compromise amongst people
about the quality of what they sell and
all of these also misunderstood
in other words quality starts if a
customer doesn't need it
it doesn't provide something that
they're going to pay for
are we have different technical terms in
my are technical terms of lambda
you know everybody understands what that
is you got a slam-dunk product or do you
have a good product for us we have
pitched several products a week
if it's a good product we don't go out
there and so it's got to be slammed up
it's got to be where
nobody refuses and then you have a hard
time
so
law is really they don't have the
promise definition of a good product it
will do well
now there's some amount of execution
I would say if you don't have a great
product
any amount of execution is going to only
buy you a little time after that
everybody will figure out this is not
that good and not buy it anymore we have
what I call when I hire somebody or
that's going to join our firm we have
what's called the prime directive which
is if anyway if you ever seen Star Trek
there's a prime directive and the prime
directive and our company is no
aggravation okay nobody gets to give us
aggravation whether it's customers
vendors employees if you aggravate you
got to go it sets them because and it's
really business because usually it's the
one percent you know some customer
that's got one percent of your business
he's driving you nuts and he's taking up
80% of your head how is that business so
aggravation is the largest cost in
business to me it's really simple we
live here after work if an employee is
such that they're going to cause all
kinds of havoc they're going to
aggravate we need to go one time one of
our senior guys yelled at a receptionist
so I call them in I said look you can't
yell at it you can fire which is that
bad they need to go but we live here
don't mess up this air this place and
we've found that aggravation is if you
avoid it not only do you have fun but it
is it's a great place to work and nobody
quits I mean we can't get people to quit
we have basically I mean out of those 70
people I think we lose about one a year
and and it's to an on job you know it's
like okay there they don't want to work
anymore
they're going to three days a week or we
have almost no turnover because there's
no aggravation there so there's huge
benefits come from a simple concept most
of the people that watch this are
relatively rich people right I mean and
most of them are going to earn a living
they'll eat
live you know they'll be fine beyond
that there should be something to do
that's useful that's something that says
okay I did something I didn't just work
on the door latch all my life or
something you know what not to say door
latches are bad I mean I'm sure guys
work on their latches and that's awesome
but at the end of your life you want to
say did I do something of value or in
the beginning or in the middle you know
if every day you go to work and it's
like office space you know where I you
did yeah do I care does anybody care if
that's what it's gonna be then get paid
less do something useful you're gonna be
way better off and and chasing money I
never chase money you know people ask me
well when did you decide to give it away
I never in the problem is I never was
interested in having a toys right but
it's one of those if you're trying don't
try it happens it's in a cool factor you
said it's sort of when I was young
anyway if you're trying to be cool you
weren't okay it's so it's it's sort of
if you do that that which is has value
you're much better off the first step of
thinking things through is to go to the
customers find out what they need don't
just ask them it's like anything else if
you ask a customer what they need
they'll give you the wrong answer you
have to go there and really think
through what happened and then you'll
see what's really needed is so obvious
we have I mean we have our own jargon to
some extent like for example somebody
comes to me the project or product that
we're going to go sell or some some
project I ask them is it slam-dunk you
know and no it's really good that's a
no-no is it slam-dunk so but but it
really it's a good product and what it
does is it totally clarifies their mind
that oh no it's not slam done then then
I say well why are we going to do it so
our standards are high we have these
simple things which which
to clarify the mind not totally you know
mess up your mind or have so much jargon
that nobody knows what you're talking
about but yeah you got all the right
words like equals eco sister you know
everybody's got an eco systems here you
know or you know value propositions no
no no guy just got some good stuff to
people who need it you know so I all of
that jargon all it does is very common
sense so the idea is that you get simple
somebody asked me in on the interview so
what what does an entrepreneur really
need so I have the only two things
common sense and a sense of urgency
that's it and they'll ask me who do
should we learn this stuff for and my
answer was from your mom because she's
probably done more management than your
MBA professor
you know because it's got a budget you
got all these kids running around hard
to manage all of this hang has to be
done every day seven days a week
now that's work that's hard work that's
learning on the job and people say oh
she's just a homemaker that's a that's a
good low Lea thing no it's not that's it
that's great media and people say oh no
you know you're saying well women should
be homemakers no no that's the most
hardest work there is it's the most
talent you need us the guys go out there
and work eight hours that any idiot can
do that so it's it's sort of thinking
based on description in another words if
you look at any word and you really
think about it then you understand it
otherwise you just use these words that
everybody uses and they think okay now
this guy must know something after all
you know he knows what an ecosystem is
so our approach to things like I said is
is different you may agree with it I'm
sure many at some mba professor I mean
one time the U of M you know she of
Michigan Roscoe called me to speak I
said you guys kidding so I said I you
know I think of MBAs I think it's
totally useless so you know I'll come
over so that's a fine that's what you
want
so I went over there and kind of defined
it I said look I mean I'm not saying
that they don't teach anything of value
I mean I think they teach this much that
is useful then teach this much that is
useless and then they teach this much
that's harmful so overall you know
averages on the useless side because you
come out of school and you actually
think you know something really you know
and that's dangerous because you really
don't
so I never hire people out of fancy
schools for that reason my first
question usually is to an MBA how are
you going to get over it
so and I'm not I'm really not alone in
this the good guys have met the chief
executives I've met of really large
companies that are you know that don't
usually they get in front of podium and
it's all PC lawyer you know lawyer
cleared stuff so they don't say anything
but the good guys that I've met they're
all sick of MBAs really they're not
really enamored of this whole thing
because that you know look it's a simple
thing if you're gonna learn plumbing go
learn from a plumber that's actually
seen a pipe you know has fixed a leak
not just written about pipes and
lectured on pipes and research pipes
it's it's
so I I'm not for Theoretical plumbers
thank you so much for watching I made
this video because Nick the Greek 82
asked me to so if there's a famous
entrepreneur that you want me to profile
next leave in the comments below and
I'll see what I can do
I'd also love to know which of the top
10 rules was your favorite had the
biggest impact on you on why leave it in
the comments and I'm going to join the
discussion thank you so much for
watching
continue to believe and I'll see you
soon